okay thanks though it's wonderful to be
here back in sunny Southern California
or California right I did my PhD work in
Southern California it's nice to be back
in the Sun because now I'm up in Seattle
she's a little bit Rainier turns out um
so you might also know that right here
in Berkeley we're sitting right on top
of the Hayward Fault Line so let's just
imagine for a second this room started
shaking all right major earthquake event
happens think about after that shaking
stopped what would you do okay so for
many of us we might be thinking okay
what just happened right if you have
never experienced an earthquake before
you might also sink am I still in danger
do I need to evacuate this building are
my family and friends okay and all of
these kinds of questions come up during
crisis events and it's actually very
well established in the social sciences
that what do people do to answer these
questions they turn to their social
networks all right so you might turn to
the neighbor your neighbor the person
sitting next to you discuss what
happened try to think about what to do
next I'm you might call family and
friends and you might get on social
media all right so you might open up
Twitter to see what other folks are
saying about what just happened so this
is what I want to talk about today um
social behavior during crisis events and
what's really interesting about this
context is that the social behavior
unfolds um in conditions of extreme
stress all right very disrupted settings
non-routine situations you don't
experience a lot of these in your
lifetime and so the decisions that you
make in this context and in the actions
that you take can quite literally have
life-altering consequences so this is
our topic for today and in in line with
many of the other things we've heard
about throughout the day today I'm going
to argue that we can better understand
this kind of social behavior during
crisis by making use of digital trace
data right of the things that we do on
the internet so hopefully what we learn
in this endeavor will not only help us
improve
response and recovery strategies but it
will allow us to reduce human losses
economic losses and potentially mitigate
these kind of long-standing damage that
happens to affected communities okay so
sociologists have been studying this
kind of social interaction during crisis
for a really long time and we don't
think of crisis as a very narrow thing
we actually think very broadly about
crisis so this can be natural disasters
it can be civil or political unrest it
can be acts of terrorism that have these
all fun fall under our umbrella of
crisis so today I'm going to talk about
a few different kinds of crises now
crises are really interesting because
they're shocks to the social system all
right so major of exogenously and they
reveal core behavioral patterns they
also reveal the social factors that
might constrain those kind of behaviors
so um some of the key behaviors that
happen during crisis events include
things like information seeking exchange
dissemination those are sort of many
often times the first questions you
think about after a disaster events all
right rumor een is a slightly more
complex phenomena where people are
trying to make sense of right
collectively make sense of what just
happened and what's going on things like
coordination and improvisation are also
very prevalent because this is a non
routine situation and we have to respond
to it individuals and groups and
organizations and everybody together and
finally mass convergence describes the
tendency for people information and
materials to all converge on the
physical area of impact right contrary
to sort of some assumptions that people
make normally we don't see mass sort of
like people fleeing from disasters you
see a lot of convergence so I'm going to
focus on two of these things today and
we don't have time to talk about them
all which our room ring and mass
convergence of attention in particular
so we're going to discuss the ways in
which digital data and computational
techniques right computational social
social science and data science can help
us
to better understand these phenomena and
the consequences of these phenomena so
let's look at rumor and behavior first
alright so as social scientist we don't
actually restrict our definition of
rumor to just mean false information
things of doubtful truth and we actually
think very broadly about what rumor is
and for us rumor is going to simply be
stories that are unverified at the time
that they're being talked about right so
so this is what we think about as rumors
and early studies of rumor in that came
out of the social sciences are very
theoretical driven because it's hard to
get data on rumors right think about
trying to go into a crisis affected area
people are going to have better things
to do than answer your survey questions
about did they hear this information who
they hear it from did they pass it along
and so on okay so some examples of this
kind of classic theory driven work are
all port and postman's work that is a
sort of a classic in this area but they
they sort of theorize hypothesize that
rumor spread is determined by the
importance of the information the
uncertainty surrounding that information
and the information how that information
might suggest behavioral changes right
what you might do so we can actually
test some of these theories using
behavioral trace data um and what's
interesting about rumery is that some
people think about Ramona's a bad thing
right Andrew marine actually serves a
very particular social function during
these kind of disrupted studies where it
allows people to alleviate their anxiety
and then actually make decisions and
take actions in the face of extreme
uncertainty because it allows them to
improvise news right and this is the
case when official channels might be
unavailable or just not very timely
right so people have to make sense some
things together okay so I'm going to
talk about the ways that we try to
understanding this collective sense
making process of room wearing and this
is work that expands a number of
projects in a number of
collaborations but what I want to focus
on today is a particular portion of this
project that is to ames right so our
aims are twofold first we want to better
understand the social dynamics of this
process of room rain by mapping patterns
of rumor in overtime and looking
specifically at how people engage with
this kind of rumor related content
online and our second aim is to actually
use crowd correction alright so the
tendency for people to deny or challenge
information to identify misinformation
right by that I mean false rumors so if
we can do this then potentially we can
help out you know the poor unsuspecting
soul who sees this tweet that was posted
during Hurricane sandy and actually
thinks that sharks are you know roaming
the neighborhoods of Manhattan in New
Jersey and they decide ok I can't go
outside right I might get eaten by a
shark ok um so our end goal is
ultimately to help with emergency
management and emergency responders are
actually quick very quick to cite the
potential for rampant misinformation
online as one of the major reasons that
they're very reluctant to fully
incorporate social media into disaster
recovery management strategies right but
if we can better understand how
misinformation flows through populations
in these kind of online public's then we
can potentially give them guidelines to
combat this very detrimental
misinformation that can really affect
the safety of communities ok so how do
we actually go about doing this I want
to spend a little bit of time talking
about the process involved with these
kind of computational social science
studies and I think this is actually one
area that tends to get under emphasized
and it's not easy all right so first
thing we have to do is be able to
collect data right we want to collect
data on crisis related social media
posts we want to then identify rumors
within that content some rumors that are
being talked about at that time then we
have to think about actually defining
the boundaries of those rumors right
labeling them because we want to
understand how people engage with social
media content and this means we manually
read every one of these tweets and
encode it and then finally we get to a
point where we can actually analyze data
right so we have a bunch of data and we
can think about analyzing that data with
whatever techniques we're going to use
to address our aims okay so I want to
talk specifically about some of the
challenges that our eyes because at
every point in this process you
encounter challenges right then we have
to deal with them our strategy has been
to incorporate statistical learning
methods to augment qualitative
approaches right so we have both ends of
the spectrum here okay so we have to
first collect data and the choices that
we make about sampling digital data are
extremely important right because they
can have a very large effect on the
analysis that you do it these kind of
choices define what you include in the
data set you're going to analyze and
equally important they define what's
excluded ok so we identify a crisis
event we have to think about making very
rapid decisions oops did I go too far
sorry we have to make very rapid
decisions about what search terms to use
to collect data right and we just with
the Twitter API and you have to do this
inanimate information space that's
evolving over time okay so not an easy
problem and at u-dub we have a team of
student researchers who are sort of
monitoring breaking events and then
they're learning how to curate these
kind of keyword sets that we use to
sample data and all of this is built on
a huge sort of platform software that we
wrote to query and access and archive
data from the Twitter API okay so we
have data now we have to identify rumor
stories and importantly we have to
define the boundaries of those stories
okay so this can be really challenging
because stories aren't just the same
over time right they change they permute
they evolve and we need to understand
where one rumor ends in the next one
begins right not the most
straightforward thing out there so we
have a story let's say we can define it
we then have to think about all the data
we have in our data sets thats related
to that story so identify all these
relevant tweets in our case and we have
to do this with both high precision and
high recall right if we have too much
noise and then we waste the resources of
our human coders we're just asking them
to code a bunch of nonsense and if we
have too many missing cases that means
we're potentially neglecting a lot of
these crowd corrections that were really
interested in because the crowd
corrections tend to you use non-standard
language they sometimes even lack very
explicit reference to the rumor itself
okay so let's say we have some data it's
related to a rumor then we go through
and we manually read every tweet and we
code it right so we have a coding scheme
that we've developed that thinks about
annotating every one of these posts with
their stamps towards the rumor as well
well as well as other elements and we
have to train our coders to be able to
do this reliably across rumor events and
across different crisis events so
obviously this task is very resource
intensive and I can only ask
undergraduates to read and code so many
tweets so this is one area where we
incorporate a lot of computational
techniques as well so we use machine
learning methods to also automatically
try to classify each of these message
messages and then this is one area where
we have incorporated data science
techniques with really great effects so
here's a recent study that we did that
looks at data from rumors of that
happened during the 2014 hostage crisis
in Sydney Australia so what happened
during this event is a gunman took
control of a cafe took hostages there
were lots of rumors going on because
there were rumors of involvement by Isis
and all kinds of things that happened
this event eventually ended when police
stormed the cafe the gunman was killed
and some of the hostages were killed as
well so across multiple rumours that
we've identified in this data both true
rumors and false rumors we manually code
these tweets as affirming the rumor or
denying the rumor all right so I just
want to talk really quickly about this
distinction between affirm and deny we
also have neutral tweets we also code
for other kinds of elements but in the
interest of time I'm not going to talk
too much about all of those other things
so we a coat we code things as a firmer
deny we have a simple classification
problem here and all this manually coded
data becomes our training data hmm so
then um we do some experiments with
various statistical models right so we
try things like logistic regression
naive bayes random forest models and we
do pretty well ok so we extract a bunch
of features based on the tweet
characteristics text elements and user
characteristics like things like n-grams
and parts of speech and so on um and we
can achieve an accuracy of around eighty
eight percent right across our on
average across our different models so
this is pretty good if you compare it
with a baseline of sixty-six percent
which is just if you predict the
dominant category or so not bad um and
one of the things that's really
interesting about this is because you
can feed the machine learning algorithm
as many tweets as you want right it
allows us to scale up our manual coding
okay so not only can we then apply these
annotation approaches to very high
volume rumors but it also allows us to
use prior observations to inform the
coding of new data right things we
haven't seen yet now um there's lots of
important questions to be asked about
this kind of automated coding most
importantly right when we get to our
fourth box over here when we want to
analyze data for whatever our quantity
of interest is going to be we want to
ask whether that human coding and that
machine coding lead to the same
inferences about that quantity so this
is a great question for future work and
we'll see what happens
um okay so um I want to talk a little
bit about the ways that we analyze room
right there are many ways we can do this
and we do approach this from many
different angles but I'm not going to
talk about all of them today what I do
want to talk about is just trying to
understand room or prevalence right so
many previous studies of rumor and also
look at prevalence and they tend to
measure prevalence by just the number of
messages that we see in the environment
raise a volume and I'm this is data that
comes from that same Sydney event this
is a rumor about police raids that were
supposedly going on during the the
crisis and you can see the volume
signature and these sort of light um
time series lines here ok so but if we
actually think back to many of the
social theories of room rain right from
the from the past then they're not
really about volume of messages right
there about number of people who have
seen those messages so we also want to
estimate the size of the exposed
population and we can try to do that by
just weighing each of our messages by
estimates of the audience for that
particular author all right so we do
that and exposure is represented in
these blocked bars here so if you can't
see it exactly the blah the bar is made
up of a bunch of little blocks & in the
size of those blocks is the size of the
audience for that one tweet so we have
volume and we have exposure and the
first thing you see hopefully in this
picture is that they look different all
right so if you're going to measure
prevalence with volume and you're going
to measure prevalence with the size of
the exposed population these trends
wouldn't match up right so you can see
places here we r you know there's a
small spike in volume there's a giant
spike in exposure I know you can see
other places where there's spikes in
volume but not very much exposure
so what's going on well I find it
helpful sometimes to look at very
concrete examples so let's take a look
um here's one example that can help us
understand what's going on so as I said
this rumor is about the Australian
Federal Police at conducting raids in a
particular neighborhood with in Sydney
and what happened at this particular
point in time here that's labeled to was
this tweet ok so the Australian Federal
Police media account posts this message
that says um these rumors are wrong
right this isn't actually happening and
we dig into this case a little bit more
in detail we see that this account had
you know a few thousand followers at the
time but if we estimate the derivative
volume that they exposed people to this
content we find that almost two million
users could have been exposed to this
particular message right how did this
happen people pass this message on ok so
the network structure is really
important to the diffusion process here
and across all of the rumors in our data
and many different events that we've
studied we see that both the network
features of the people who are involved
in these conversations as well as the
content of the messages they post both
of these two things interact to
structure the diffusion process and the
rumour dynamic static things are we
comparing with the left hand y axis and
which things are so so number of tweets
is volume and the bars are exposure
number of tweets is the lines yes these
ones the lines of against the flyers
yeah I don't care so much about the
numbers and actually I hate putting two
Y axes on one plot but I just wanted to
show you that you know the two things
don't track exactly yeah okay so we
could come and put this together and one
thing that we've found helpful is to
actually construct this kind of typology
for identifying these kind of important
points within the rumor signature okay
so I'm going to talk about each of these
sort of 44 typology characteristics of
things because we've found them helpful
in conceptualising how things happen
over time okay so we're going to start
with Giants here and we know that some
social medias have social media users
have really large audiences I think
Justin Bieber and so he posts a
particular message it gets really picked
up by people they respond to it they
pass it along and it just kind of leads
to this giant cascade all right there
really Giants within the conversation so
but we also know that not all messages
from these high exposed highly visible
people lead to these giant cascades okay
so we also have people where they have a
large audience but their tweets kind of
fizzle but nothing really happens with
them all right and likewise those with
small audiences can also make waves in
this kind of conversation so we do see
messages that start from very less
visible users right but they get picked
up by the crowd and they keep moving on
and on long until they can dominate the
conversation are just like snowballs
that are rolling down a hill and finally
we just have a bunch of messages from a
bunch of people that nobody cares about
and this is kind of the babble of all
this kind of noise within social media
so um one of the things that this
typology emphasizes and we found it
helpful to think about rubrene dynamics
is the fact that retransmission of
content is key okay so people have to
pass things along so what do people
decide to pass on all right open
question we're working on it right how
do they react differently to different
kinds of messages or even the way that
content is designed right if you put
things in all caps are they going to
pass it along more than if you don't
and importantly how fast do these kind
of rumors spread during crisis events
this is a particular interesting
question for crisis because often the
information is extremely time-sensitive
right it doesn't do any good to get an
evacuation notice after the event has
already concluded so we are going to
compare the speed of retransmission for
these kind of rumor message rumor
related messages because we want to know
if denials can actually outpaced
affirmations right if you have a fast
reaction to content can that denial
spread faster on the social network then
these affirmations of content so we
actually we do that and when I'm
comparing here are waiting times median
waiting times so the time between when
the original message was posted in each
instance of retransmission of that
message so the top figure here shows
random tweets crisis related tweets but
not rumor once and then rumor tweets
okay so what you see is random has
really sort of on average long waiting
times Christ people tend to respond to
crisis information faster and they tend
to respond to rumors even faster okay
and on the bottom plot here i'm just
showing for those rumor tweets a firm
versus deny tweets right so what do we
see the denials have a slightly shorter
waiting time than affirmations all right
this is just a figure but obviously we
do this with a statistical model and we
actually show they have a statistically
significantly shorter waiting time yes
what is it prices really that's not as a
month so it can just be like about the
event and so in particular let's say I
showed you that rumor before about
police raids that are going on if I were
to just touch a post a tweet that says
there's a hostage situation going on at
this cafe that's not about the rumor but
it is about the event
why is that oh because it uh well it's
good question at that point it confirmed
that this event is going on and so by
our definition of room where it doesn't
hold but it's also not part of one of
the specific rumors we're looking at in
this case yeah good question okay um so
retransmission speed so we've learned a
lot about ramin over the course of this
project just a couple things to think
about before I talk about mass
convergence rumor is a very natural
social behavior and in an often emerges
during crisis events because of the
heightened level of uncertainty that's
going on during those situations right
it's really important to understand how
rumor spread and how people engage with
room or content for crisis management
right we have seen that online crowds
can actually be effective at making
sense of uncertain to information and
they can be good at correcting
misinformation as well okay so we want
to look at rumors not only in terms of
volume which is the typical way that
things are done but also in terms of
exposure and finally um we need to
understand we need to better understand
these propagation mechanisms right
things like retransmission and we need
to know that they can potentially have
different impacts online than they would
in word of mouth right a great example
of this is distortion right a lot of the
early work on rue marine was really
focused on distortion because you know
think about the telephone game I say
something to you you say something to
somebody else but the end time it gets
to the end it might look completely
different all right this is a very
different process than twitter where I
click a button in the same message gets
posted and and sent to my followers okay
so we need to reformulate and extend
some of our theories to think about
rubery okay so I want to spend um the
latter part of my time today thinking
about another really important social
behavior which is mass convergence okay
just so just like rue marine mask
convergence specifically of attention
happens a lot during crisis events and
this is a phenomenon where individuals
and organizations can experience
extremely drastic changes in their
personal network structure okay so mass
convergence happens offline as well and
we see that people and information and
materials all converge to the physical
geographic area of impact following
disasters and what's really interesting
about this particular behavior is that
it represents this extreme departure
from what's normal social behavior right
it's not every day you just sort of like
drop everything and rush to help
somebody at a particular crisis event
and you might fly across the country or
across the world to go help out in these
kinds of situations so convergence
behavior is now mirrored and I would
argue potentially enhanced or extended
and online contexts so just look back at
the most recent crisis event we have a
global audience that turns to social
media to follow what's going on with
that disaster we see digital volunteers
mobilize to coordinate relief efforts
and help raise you know funds and money
and supplies for the people who are
affected by disasters right then all of
this happens online right there are many
new modes of public participation in
emergency management so if you if you're
not convinced yet let me show you a
couple examples so we see mass
convergence all over the place so here
are some data and some figures from a
recent study that we did that looks at
the information behaviors of emergency
responders okay what did they say on
Twitter what do they do in these online
environments so we wanted to estimate
sort of general conversation that they
were posting so we have a set of
nationally representative emergency
responders all of their tweets for the
past four years and we fit a basic lda
topic model on this and we compared
behaviors across accounts and then we
look to see what do they say on
days when there's no major disaster
event in the US and what did they say on
days when there is a major disaster
event right so hopefully I've already
given away the punch line right we see
convergence right so if you look at
these two figures um what's going on
well all of these accounts start talking
about the same thing they start talking
about the disaster so this isn't
necessarily surprising but we see it
very clearly right so if you were
confused about what's going on in this
plot this is just a multi-dimensional
scaling of the similarity between
accounts it's a physical distance
between points here is a representation
of their similarity or likewise distance
in each one of our points is on account
okay we also see mass convergence of
attention in social networks and so here
is some data where we're just looking at
the number of followers of a particular
emergency management account it's the
same set of counts I talked about in the
past and what happens here when during
the Boston Marathon bombing is the
Massachusetts Emergency Management
Agency has like orders of magnitude
change in the number of people paying
attention to them on Twitter right same
thing happens for New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie right during Hurricane
sandy so in the language of social
networks what happens here well there's
really really major changes in people's
personal networks right the size of
those networks the number of connections
their degree changes crazy changes in
the span of you know a few hours or
protect potentially a few days so this
masked this kind of mass convergence of
attention can be a really great
opportunity right it can fill facilitate
information diffusion it gives you
direct access to potentially more people
may be members of that affected
community and it also gives you in
direct access to a lot more people
because you just have a lot more ties
right it can also have very large costs
hey any mistakes you make are very much
made in the public eye so over and over
again and our
are in our studies we see that local
emergency responders are often the
target for this kind of convergence of
attention so these tiny little counts
that nobody's ever heard of before all
of a sudden becomes this major celebrity
like figure during these crisis contacts
okay so our one of our newest projects
in this area seems seeks to characterize
these kind of degree dynamics all right
so first thing we want to do is look at
baseline growth over time right you saw
those plots that I just showed there
tends to be this gradual increase in the
number of followers people have and our
preliminary analysis shows that that's
can be consistent across these
organizations all right second thing we
want to do is be able to predict the
incidents and the magnitude of these
convergence events and it looks like we
can do that by just looking at when
disasters happen where where they happen
and who they happen to and what type of
event they are i should say okay and and
finally our last goal is to think about
decay okay decay of relationships over
time if you think back to those two
plots I showed there was barely any
decay and I think that is really
interesting preliminary result because
it means that you can then capitalize on
this increase of attention ok so we've
collected data for this nationally
representative set of emergency
management organizations on Twitter we
have snapshots of their personal
networks at daily resolution for the
past four or five years right so really
cool data um here's just a look at that
what that raw data looks like so here
I'm just showing you the change in
audience size number of followers right
personal network degree for these actors
as a function of their size the previous
day so there's a lot of growth here but
the main point that i want to emphasize
is highlighted with these sort of red
points up here right orders of magnitude
change in your network in just 24 hours
so um we see that this happens a lot for
local emergency responders right most of
those points tend to be local
organizations in the areas where
disaster events happen we know
surprisingly little about how these
emergency responders behave online right
and we know even less about their online
audiences right who is paying attention
to them can they stop the spread of
misinformation or not right does what
they post matter how do people pay
attention to and pass along their tweets
so these are the kinds of questions
we're trying to explore in this project
and just to show you some preliminary
results we are studying the audience's
of police precincts okay so police
accounts are often the first responders
during crisis events and this data
differs a little bit from some of our
previous data and it's starts in an
offline way okay so first thing we do is
we think about a geographic region that
we want to study i'm going to show you
seattle which shouldn't be a surprise
giving them from seattle um so we start
in Seattle we list all the police
precincts right ignoring Twitter first
time we don't really care about Twitter
um that means we have a really well
defined population of users right which
doesn't often happen when you think
about digital data so we have a
well-defined population of user as we go
look to see which ones have Twitter
accounts um we collect data about the
location of where they're supposed to be
serving right there beat as we would
call it and the demographic
characteristics of those constituents
and we use that with US census data we
can estimate those things and then we go
to Twitter and we collect data about
what they post and their follower graphs
are in so their social networks on
Twitter then we actually use geotagged
tweets from their audience members to
try to infer demographic characteristics
about the online audience right so if I
see that your audience members post a
lot of geotagged tweets in a particular
location I go look on the census about
what the racial composition or
demographic composition is in that area
okay so we have these times
series and followers we have census data
we have all sorts of different things
here so here is on the network of police
precincts at Seattle and each one of
these nodes is one of the beats right
Seattle beat accounts that each have
individual accounts in the one the big
node down here is just the general
Seattle PD account so the nodes are
connected here if they have significant
overlap in their audiences all right so
two nodes are connected they share a lot
of audience members and what you see
here is if you're familiar with Seattle
there's a lot of geographic clustering
right so all these nodes up here are the
northern Seattle neighborhoods then you
can sort of move into downtown South
Seattle West yellow so not super
surprising um but let's take a look at a
couple so here are two seattle accounts
they correspond to neighborhoods in
seattle one of them's in north seattle
sort of the Wallingford area the other
ones in south seattle ins are columbia
city if you know CL or been to visit
either of those places and wallingford's
in northern seattle neighborhoods are
very not racially diverse and the ones
in south seattle are much more racially
diverse
okay so here's what we do we compare the
estimated racial composition of the
online audience with the populations
that are served by these precincts okay
so in this plot the orange bars
represent the racial characteristics of
the population that is served by these
police accounts and the blue bars
represent the estimated racial
composition of the online audience for
those same place accounts so a higher
blue bar here means that compared with
the offline demographics and that the
particular racial group is much more
over-represented on Twitter right and
the flip is the other way around so what
we see is really interesting differences
hey this is the predominantly white
neighborhood in Seattle we see that
actually some of these non-white groups
are over-represented in the Twitter
audience this is the really racially
more racially diverse neighborhood of
Seattle right we see that whites are
much more likely to follow that police
account on Twitter okay so let's just
say for the sake of argument that the
Seattle Police Department decides all
Christ crisis communications going to be
via Twitter what would that mean right
it would mean that we have systemic
inequality in information access and
exposure right and it would also mean
that when crisis events happen we would
likely see differences in disaster
outcomes like survival or long-term
well-being that were even more
exaggerated between these racial groups
we already know they're exaggerated
right even more exaggerated because they
have differential access to information
so luckily this is unlikely to happen
but evidence really suggests that these
kind of drastic changes in personal
network structure exists right and
they're not that uncommon so I think
there's really interesting theoretical
and practical implications of this kind
of mass convergence behavior
and we see that emergency responders are
often the target for this kind of
attention but we don't really understand
the characteristics or the biases in the
online audiences of these organizations
and we need to know more about them so
we want to think about how a better
understanding of this convergence
behavior can allow these organizations
to make use of the opportunity and avoid
the cost of attention okay so I'm
probably out of time for J so let me
just wrap up hopefully I've shown you a
little bit about how digital data
digital traces these digital footprints
we leave online can be valuable for
understanding social behavior during
crisis they allow us to test theories in
in ways we just really couldn't do in
the past okay so we have to refined and
extend our theories but there's really
interesting things to be learned so this
this research agenda isn't cheap right
what is it entail it means we have to
make use of qualitative methods
statistical and machine learning methods
text analysis network analysis right all
kinds of different methods and it means
we have to incorporate data from a lot
of different sources right not just
social media data but census data
interview data all kinds of different
things and this is sort of multi-method
multi-modal approach is I think what
computational social science has to
offer to help improve our understanding
of social behavior during crisis events
all right so this is a large project let
me just quickly thank my collaborators
right I have a number of awesome
colleagues who helped with this work we
have a team of student researchers who
also participate in these projects and
of course we couldn't do it without our
funders so thank you
you